my name is Nikolai know what sick I am I
was in an academia until recently it was
a postdoc in mathematics at Imperial
College and at the moment I am a
consultant adequate Iranian risk
management and in this talk I'm going to
talk about spherical Voronoi diagrams
primarily about about the spherical case
but in order to understand Voronoi
diagrams it makes sense to start with
with planar Voronoi diagrams so these
are like two slightly different versions
of the same thing um in both cases I
will try to give you an introduction
that is as intuitive as possible I will
tell you how to formally write down
these problems and of course we will
discuss how to solve from the problem of
computing or more diagrams in Python and
in the second part I would also like to
highlight why this is a particularly a
particularly a PI data story um and
hopefully the end you will understand
what that means okay so let's start with
with the first part on the plane the
Voronoi diagram some these look like
this so the easiest way to to understand
this is that maybe you just think of
this of this graphic you see here as an
simplified map of London so imagine
you're somewhere in London and you want
to travel around and these dots you see
here are on the black dots these are
representing tube stations in London
it's just a simplified version you can
roughly see the circle line and like a
diagonal Piccadilly line through that
and so if you are at some point of the
plane um in this map you might wonder
what is the closest tube station to you
and the Voronoi diagram is exactly on
what gives you this information so if
you are at any point um maybe around
here then this red shaded region is
exactly the set of points where this
tube station here is closest and the
Voronoi diagram computes this
information for every point in the plane
so for for every for every point of the
plane that tells you what generator
point is closest to you um so
if you have for instance like in near
this tube station somewhere somewhere
here in this orange shaded region then
this is exactly the region where this
tube station is closest and as you can
see on the Voronoi diagram gives you a
petition of the entire plane into these
regions of closest distance to the tube
stations and the colors here I just
chosen randomly so up sorry um the
colors here just chosen randomly so this
is what a diagram looks like and if you
would like to play around with this
yourself I really would suggest that you
do this at some point maybe later after
the talk or so you can go to this
website by Lex portal and here's just a
web app that way I really can like click
and show on a blitz um put in some
points and then it gives you a voronoi
diagram like this and he has kindly
allowed me to use this graphics in this
talk so thank you very much um yeah so
in general the input into this voronoi
diagram always is a set of points and
the output always is a set of regions
surrounding these points and these
regions represent the the points of
closest distance to this point there is
one interesting thing you can see within
this diagram here on there slightly
there are two different types of regions
if you look in the in the center where
we have to pick a dually line inside the
circle line these regions are of finite
size for instance some this this green
one here arm is bounded by these
vertices here and this region is
finitely big but the orange region here
um this would be infinitely large if you
really had an infinitely large map if
this really isn't just a map of London
but really the mathematical plane are to
which infinitely spreads into all
directions then this would be a voronoi
cell which is infinitely big whereas
this is only finitely a finite a big ok
so I hope you've got some intuition on
the on the plane a voronoi diagram um
there is an abstract mathematical
definition on which I just put in here
for for reasons of completeness you can
define Voronoi diagrams in a very
general sense you can define it in a
so-called metric space on this is basic
anything where you can measure distances
and then this definition basically is
the same as for the Euclidean case so
the input is at Apple p 1 2 PK of points
which we call generator points and then
on the diagram comprises of a voronoi
region for each of these points and for
the case point the Voronoi region is
defined as follows it is the set of all
points that are closest to the cave
point and closest in a general sense
means that the distance arm is smallest
among the distances to all the other
points if that that that abstract
formulation doesn't help you you can
just skip it i mean it's really just the
formalization in an in formula of this
intuitive idea i've just shown you this
this table is p 1 2 PK these are
religious this really just an
enumeration of these black dots and this
are 1 2 RK these regions these
correspond to these colorfully shaded
regions and of course um this this
object is very well understood it's
considered to be a standard piece of of
mathematics it had also been studied by
computer scientists but people from
computational geometry and it's
considered a rather standard problem I
think since the 60s or so and as a hmm
even in cosmology fantastic um so it's
very broad applications and as a result
a lot of stuff is known about these
diagrams for instance it is known that
under very general conditions in the
Euclidean plane on this problem is
always solvable and you even know that
the shape of these regions on these will
always be convex polytopes and this is
very good because if you think about how
to store this information of a diagram
the fact that this is a convex polytope
means essentially that you only have to
store on these vertices of this region
and then you know that this is the
region surrounding this point so it
cannot happen that's like a very real
curved shaped a region um in one of the
Voronoi diagrams okay so um if you're
more interested in the and the
practicalities of of using Voronoi
diagrams or i would suggest that you
take a look at a scifi and matplotlib
because with these two libraries you can
handle
voronoi diagrams in a very easy way so
essentially all you have to do is if if
these are your if these are your
generator points then all you have to do
is you have to create an umpire array
and put these points into this numpy
array and then you can just use
matplotlib to plot them and then you get
this result by the way in the end of the
talk i will give you a link for an eye
python notebook on github which you can
check out and play around with this
yourself if you would like to use this
at some point okay so these are the
generator points and if you want to
actually compute the Voronoi diagram you
have to use the Voronoi class from Sify
spatial and once you import this class
all you have to do is you have to put
your points into this voronoi class and
then this year is an is an object that
does all the calculations for you so
this war variable um contains all the
information of this of this diagram and
if you want to plot it the only thing
you have to do is you have to import
voronoi plot 2d and put this calculator
diagram into that function together with
an excess object and then as you can see
um you get a plot with the generator
points and these surrounding regions
maybe we see that in succession so I
mean these are the generator points and
here you can see the split of the plane
again into these regions of closest
distance these dashed um these dashed
lines here are so these lines are dashed
because um this is a again a polytope
that sort of goes to infinity it tries
to distinguish these polytopes that are
sort of only finitely big from the ones
that have yeah you could say a vertex at
infinity okay so very easy to do on to
do volunteer grams in in Python once you
have numpy matra flip and this class
from Sify special there's another class
which might be interesting if you work
with this i briefly would like to show
you of this class and this is something
which is called the deloney
triangulation and the easiest way to
think about the deloney triangulation is
as follows so if you look at this set of
points um then just think about the
obvious way to connect these points with
lines this would be like this and
roughly speaking this is the diwali
triangulation so
is sort of the the most canonical way to
to triangulate a set of points and this
can also be done using this library from
from Sify spatial so you simply import
the lonely from side by spatial you give
it your points and then you can plot the
computer diagram using on this stripe
lot very good question so as I just said
so the term like obvious triangulation
isn't mathematically very well defined
if you want an exact definition of a de
l'année triangulation here it is so the
knowledge so if you say if you have a
set of points you can triangulate the
set of points this basically means that
you connect the points with triangles
but sometimes this is not unique there
are multiple ways as you just said how
to connect points two triangles and the
deloney triangulation um tries to do
this in a very special way so the the
correct definition is that if P is the
set of points which we have just seen
then it'll only try the triangulation is
at the lonely triangulation if the
circum hyper spheres of any simplex to
contain no point of P that might not
seem totally intuitive at the first
lancer the important information here is
that sometimes triangulating points is
not unique so if you have only four
points for instance like these you could
connect them or like this or like this
and this duel only triangulation is
supposed to be very robust and to to be
very compatible with processes like
refinement and doing numerical
computations and so on we won't need it
in a lot of detail I just mentioned it
here because the de'longhi triangulation
is often mentioned in parallel with
these Voronoi diagrams I'll show you in
a second why yeah basically the the
easiest way to compute it along
strangulation without python is really
you give this set of points to a
five-year-old child and say connect the
points with lines and then most likely
it will get the de Launay triangulation
the reason why it's of mentioned in
connection with the Voronoi diagrams is
if you plot both graphs at the same time
you see that they're kind of Jew
there's this notion of dual graphs and
this is exactly on what you can see here
so the blue points and the blue lines
are the de l'année triangulation and the
black lines are from the Voronoi diagram
and you see that these graphs in terms
of vertices and edges on our kind of
dual so as you can see um you can
compute these these these things in
Python relatively easy just a few lines
of code and then you get your diagram
and this is basically everything you
need to know in order to work with
planar Voronoi diagrams in Python are
there any further questions regarding
the the planar case yes please
pardon me I didn't get the question
so the the input into this is always a
set of points this generator points yeah
oh you can you can you can add further
points and then it recompute the diagram
yeah yes I think so yeah it has I think
it has a function for that okay so
basically the spherical the problem of
computing spherical Voronoi diagrams is
exactly analogous to computing our plane
a Voronoi diagrams and again let's take
traveling as an example so assume you
want to travel around the world and not
only through london arm you can look at
the at the entire world and this is like
a roughly a sphere and this is a map of
the world and the the input into the
Voronoi diagram you see here is every
Airport on this planet and then you
would maybe like to know what is the
closest airport and this voronoi diagram
tells you exactly that so if you look at
this region of the of the earth you see
that there are a lot of a Voronoi
regions here this is because this
roughly corresponds to europe and europe
has a lot of efforts and here you see
like africa and this this is Russia this
is the Atlantic Ocean so not many
airports here and at this at this part
here you see the u.s. starting with
again many more airports and if you want
to compute spherical Voronoi diagrams
and just play around with it there's a
similar web app by adjacent davis who
kindly allowed me to use this in this
talk and if you want to play around with
spherical ball or more diagrams just
online by like clicking in adding some
points playing around with it um you can
for instance try on this this map app
okay so now of course the question um
the question arises on how to do this in
Python and this is exactly why this is a
PI data story so almost exactly one year
ago there was pie data done in 2015 and
there was a talk about Voronoi diagrams
or by Tyler Eddy and
if you haven't seen the talk you can
check it out on youtube and just for
curiosity so who was here at PI data
2015 oh so everybody's new perfect so um
as you can see I included the
introduction to Voronoi diagrams into my
chalk on he also started explaining
planar Borno diagrams and then moved on
to spiracle Voronoi diagrams and he
needed spherical Voronoi diagrams for
his research he's also a postdoc in he's
in Oxford and he tried to solve the case
of spherical ball no diagrams in Python
as well and unfortunately at this time
there was no ready to go implementation
for spherical Voronoi diagrams in Python
he found a few papers about the topic I
mean it's not like an unsolved
scientific mystery to discuss spherical
Voronoi diagrams there are a few papers
but sometimes these papers are then very
theoretical they tell you things like
okay so a solution exists and they try
to estimate the complexities of
algorithms that solve that but if you
really have just a notepad or some some
pycharm ide and you want to code
something that's all of that um
sometimes it's a bit it requires a bit
of work to to extract from from a
theoretical paper on how to do a
practical implementation and he was
basically at that point and um
unfortunately at this point on the
implementation he didn't didn't really
work and he basically asked the audience
if there is anyone who could help making
this happen and the interesting thing is
this talk because he posed this problem
this talk caused quite a research
collaboration so Tyler gave this talk in
2015 and at this time I was in the
audience and I'm a mathematician and my
specialty is differential geometry and
this is an part of mathematics that
studies how geometries change if you
move from flat spaces to curved spaces
and another person the audience was
recently he did a PhD in computational
geometry so a branch which studies how
to do geometry with computers and
basically out of this talk we had a chat
over there and thought like okay so we
have to be able to surf the
problem and get this running somehow in
Python and as you can see um we we
started this and then quickly more and
more people God got involved at some
point Tyler opened this pull request on
github or number five to three two of of
scifi and this initiated quite a long
discussion on how to actually implement
it on how to do it and how to integrate
this functionality into scifi as you can
see quite a lot of quite a lot of
comments a lot of commits it took quite
some time to get it actually running but
fortunately on this pull request has
recently been merged so if you ever want
to compute on a spherical voronoi
diagram in Python you can use the
current master branch of scifi or you
have to wait till the next release so
it's probably going to be in the 18
release um of the next version of scifi
and then you can actually use this
functionality okay so um if you do this
then computing a spherical ball no
diagram is actually as easy as computing
a plane a voronoi diagram because it was
our overall aim that the interface for
the spherical voronoi class which we
edit to side by spatial is as similar as
possible to the planar valla no class so
all you have to do is you have to create
an umpire array with your points this
time this points have to be on some
sphere and then you import the spherical
voronoi class and you call it and you
give its constructor the points on the
sphere and then it computes the
spherical ball annoyed diagram just as
the Voronoi class computes the plane a
voronoi diagram and the result is then
something like this so um you get a
sphere you get these black points on the
sphere and then you see these regions of
closest distances and in this case they
are like spherically their spherical
polygons surrounding these generator
points okay so this this algorithm in
the back computes computes the diagram
and you might wonder um what are the
possible applications of spherical
Voronoi diagrams and why would one want
to compute these and so the thing is I
already told you so my subject is
mathematics he does computational
geometry I didn't tell you yet Tyler
subject and this what I'm going to do
now Tyler is working in computational
biology this is a relatively new branch
that tries to or to analyze how viruses
work by means of computer models and the
viruses he is analyzing our viruses like
the dengue virus or hepatitis C and
actually the hepatitis C virus for
instance is still quite quite a serious
problem there are 200 million infections
worldwide and once you have it is
actually quite a nasty thing it causes
liver disease cirrhosis even liver
cancer and there are 350 thousand deaths
per year so it would really be good if
one could stop this this this virus and
there is new medication available so
someone who is actually infected and has
access to like modern medical healthcare
can get medication which is mostly
successful arm but very expensive but
actually it would be much better to
tackle this problem before it arises so
for hepatitis type A and B you're
probably aware that there is a
fascination just a for curiosity so who
knows that that you are fascinated
against type A or B hepatitis okay so
actually quite a lot yeah so in in many
countries is quite standard even
children get that quite early I think um
it's it's a very standard thing but for
hepatitis C you can't do it because
there is currently no vaccine available
and so there's a problem you cannot stop
this infection from spreading by means
of a vaccine so actually um this diagram
I have just shown you this could really
be a virus so I'm don't touch it um this
this appetite is C virus is very very
small which is a problem when you want
to study it because it's very difficult
apparently to directly observe what
these viruses do as you can see it is
roughly a sphere and these generator
points on that sphere they roughly
correspond to like proteins attached to
this virus and the Voronoi regions are
around them um they are like they are
important for the biologists because
they compute qualities like their
surface area and then this is used to do
this actual biology research
you as you just realized I'm not an
expert in biology I have no professional
knowledge about this at all all I know
about this is from a few conversations
with Tyler and Wikipedia so on I don't
know how exactly this viral ah gical
research has carried out but i do know
um that they use these tools to compute
these diagrams and they would really
like to sort of yeah built a better
computer model of viruses like dengue or
hepatitis C in reality these are quite
large problem instances so typically
like 10,000 or 20,000 generator points
on the sphere um so you really you
really need something like a Python
interface to compute these problems you
can't just use a web a blatant and click
in a few points I mean with 50,000
points or so this is going to be too
much work and yeah so this has now been
finished and Tyler actually went to the
US shortly in was it februari and
presented this at a big conference for
for biophysicists and other two other
computational biology people and I don't
know maybe there's more collaboration
coming up it might very well be that
other people try to use the tool and
maybe come up with with new ideas how to
tackle on this virus there are two
issues with this with this library which
we would like to address in the future
and in the tradition of these talk i
also just just post it at the problems
and if you if you would like to join in
after the talk just just say hi so the
two things we are currently working on
are the first of all the plots so as you
see this plot here of the of the
spherical voronoi diagram this doesn't
look terribly good to say the least the
problem is that the solution of the
spherical voronoi diagram comprises of
these regions here and there are
spherical II spherically convex
spherical polygons and matplotlib
doesn't have a built-in function to
build ferric polygons so what you
actually see here is I cheated I added a
lot of generator points and then I just
used this poly 3d collection to plot
these regions in 3d and because the
vertices are all on the
year this looks as if they were all on
the sphere but as you can see here in
reality they are not really exactly on
the sphere they are just slightly
slightly below that so it would be great
if matplotlib could have a functionality
that allows you to also plot spherical
polygons that might be helpful for other
purposes as well and we opened up
another another discussion here there
are a few ideas already there on maybe
in the near future this is completed
hopefully and then one gets clots about
these diagrams that look much more
pretty and the second problem is
actually to compute their surface area
and again this is not like a nun sort of
scientific mystery but you run into a
lot of practical issues for instance if
you have like a very small sphere and
lots of generator points then you often
have the problem that there are like
degeneracies in the in the polygons you
have to be really careful about
numerical instabilities and and so on
and there's another project or we
started to add this functionality in
this case to apply because some yeah
that's really like a Python computing or
library okay so in the end I would like
to say that this was my first open
source project I have worked on it was
great fun I mean the cyber community is
like really friendly you get a lot of
constructive criticism your code is
reviewed and in the end it's really cool
if you can sort of see how such a pull
request like develops and then the end
it gets released and I can only
recommend to everyone who wants to do
this just try it out it's a nice
community and we like to thank everybody
who was involved in this project namely
China for giving this talk at the last
conference for everybody who who worked
on this in between and also big thank
you to the PI data organizers because I
don't think we would have ever met at
any other conferences because although
everybody who was involved regularly
goes to scientific conferences but we
all have our our fields of expertise and
then we would have never met but this is
actually an example of a problem we have
to bring together on the expertise of
like various fields to actually a make
that happen and yeah that was really
cool so if you ever want to use the
library um please feel free to
22 to check it out it will be in the
next release or you can clone the
current master branch if you have any
other ideas on how to use spherical
Voronoi diagrams please let me know I'm
of course interested to learn what other
cool things one can do with it and if
you want to play around with it you can
go to this website so to my github and I
put a repository in there and this
contains a few examples of the of the
voluntary diagram so this is like the
planar case I have just shown you and
there are a few more Jupiter notebooks
with examples that also use the the
spherical version and then you can
already see how it would look like once
this version is actually released okay
so um yeah you can of course always get
in touch with me or about this topic and
i think that's it thank you very much
for attention while we're exactly on
time okay are there any more questions
yes please
yeah we thought about this as well
they're actually so one of these
theoretical papers actually um does the
following it takes the spherical setting
and then it projects it to the plane and
solve the problem in the plane and
projects it back to the sphere the
problem with this is if you say if you
if you imagine where is it so if you
imagine this plane herb or annoy diagram
in a being very small sitting on a very
large sphere then what would happen is
the following so if you project the
large sphere to the plane and compute
the Voronoi diagram the result you would
get would be roughly correct on this
small on the small part of the sphere
but the problem is these regions here in
the plane AB or annoy diagram that are
infinitely large they don't really make
sense on any sphere because if you have
a region in a planar born or diagram
that is infinitely large and you map
that to the sphere they start I mean the
spheres around so they will meet sort of
behind and interfere and in these parts
the Voronoi diagram will be wrong and
this is the problem if you just ignore
the fact that the sphere has a different
it's just a different type of space then
then the plane or even the entire of
three then you would have the same
problem right you which you would have
cells that are infinitely large into
into this it would be would be
infinitely large and then it's sort of
difficult to map that to the sphere bag
yeah the 3d so you want to what exactly
do you want to do you want to put yeah
okay
yes the dangers probably if you
intersect the result with a sphere you
have to sort of be careful that the
points really are on the sphere right
yes so if you have like vertices of your
diet if you have vertices of livernois
cells they might not automatically be on
the sphere and then you have to think
about how to project them accurately on
the sphere
exactly so the problem is although all
the generator points are on the sphere
if you compute it in 3d than the result
points the vertices and the regions and
and what you just said they won't
ultimately won't be on the sphere in
general and that's the problem yeah
right yes if we if we have a bit more
time I can sort of tell you a bit more
of the technical details I put that into
the end so so we basically so they're
like hmm so this solution is for for us
for an arbitrary sphere so the examples
I show you for the unit sphere but you
can take any radius or any Center and
compute it I'm not sure if that works on
an on a deformed spirit or something
yeah okay but then you quickly run to
the problem of like computing spherical
Voronoi diagrams unlike arbitrarily
differently curved spaces and I think
yeah I mean that feel free you can
improve the library with the next
request to make that happen essentially
the the algorithm I can I can show you
two things how much time do we have left
ten minutes okay I'll show you two
things um so first of all um if you
actually want to compute something you
have to think about your data structure
how to put these diagrams into any data
structure in Python and most of it is
pretty straightforward so I mean I said
just set to the points they are
basically just an umpire array and once
you compute your your your voronoi
diagram the vertices of the diagram they
are also just an umpire array in for the
for the planar case it's a 2d array and
for the spherical case it will be a 3d
array but storing these regions this is
a bit more tricky so the the way scifi
handles the the planar case is as
follows the regions of the Voronoi
diagram this will be a list of tablets
and these tuples will have integers in
it and the way to read this is as
follows so at let's say the second the
second entry of this list is supposed to
be the Voronoi regions surrounding the
can generate a point and these indices
here are the indices of the of the
Voronoi vertices that's a bit weird to
read at first but i guess this way of i
mean this is a very computationally
efficient way of storing the information
you need in order to describe these
these regions so these are the data
structures that are used for the for the
planar case as well as for the spherical
case and the algorithm arm that computes
the diagram in the spherical case does
the following so in the first step you
take the generator points on the sphere
for instance like this so the blue
points are are all these generator
points and actually what you now do is
you do use on a 3d deloney triangulation
so we just had a discussion of how to
reduce this to a 3d problem right so
this this computes the 3d a Delaunay
triangulation of the convex hull
actually which is basically the same in
this case and then you add the origin of
the sphere or the center of the three
average in this case is the origin and
then you get loads of of tetrahedra that
lie inside that sphere and because it's
slightly difficult to see to see this if
you really have all this heat or Hedra
let's take a look at one of them so
these three points are three points
three generator points on your sphere
and this point here is the origin and
what we do is we compute something which
is called the circumstellar he'd run
that is simply the smallest sphere you
can imagine where this tetrahedron still
fits in and this sphere will also have a
center and this is this red point here
in general this Center will again not be
on the original sphere itself but if you
look at it from the side so this will be
like the red point will be there will be
some are here but what you can do is you
can project this point onto the sphere
and get this red point here yes you may
have to know the radius of the sphere
exactly and then you can sort of project
that slightly onto onto the sphere and
then you get that red point and now if
you iterate this process for all these
tetrahedral I've shown you then you
a bunch of these slightly red points on
the sphere and then actually you can use
some of this theory to to show that
these are the vertices of the spherical
voronoi diagram so that actually gives
you the vertices it is a bit more tricky
to actually get these regions because if
you just have like a random randomly
ordered array of these vertices you
still have to organize this area at some
point to understand which vertices
belong to which generator and in order
to do this you really need this
neighborhood information from this
triangulation you really need to know
which points are close to which other
points which points are neighbors which
points are not neighbors um it's also
it's also helpful to have that in order
to get these points in an ordered
fashion so if you want to plot a
spherical polygon it's kind of helpful
if you have the vertices ordered like
clowns or clockwise or clockwise because
otherwise yeah because otherwise
otherwise even this pulley 3d collection
runs insane if you give it the vertices
in the wrong order it will plot like
totally weird objects and you can't see
anything at all so at the moment we have
a routine you can call and then it sorts
the vertices and then you can put it
into this poly 3d collection but the
idea is that as soon as matplotlib has
this functionality to plot spherical
polygons one would rather use that one
but as you can see if if there are loads
of generator points you can already see
more or less how this diagram will look
like so this like the the algorithm and
just just a summary so you calculate the
three DD lonnie triangulation after the
generator points you at the center of
the sphere you get a tetrahedral ization
of these points you calculate all the
circumstances of all the circumstellar
he'd run and this gives you the Voronoi
vertices and then in a second stamp you
have to use this neighborhood
information from the triangulation to
actually infer which vertices belong to
to which region and then you can at
least
see roughly how the plot looks like
using the current functionality of net
cleft lip okay thank you very much i
think i'll stop here um if you have any
further questions I will of course be
around and happy to to discuss whatever
questions you might have thank you very
much